hey what's up guys it's Marcus Brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
high-definition unboxing video today
we're going to be taking a look at a
seven or powered USB hub by say brand
yeah you heard that right this isn't a
two port USB hub or a four port USB hub
not even a five point this is a seven
port powered USB 2.0 hub it's neat
little gadget some people like to call
it a port replicator I just call it a
hub because it seems to be the more
popular name for it now that we have a
look at the packaging let's take a look
at some of the key features of this hard
work these include 2.0 speeds
plug-and-play compatibility and the
power adapter and this power adapter
means you can plug an external hard
drive or a laptop cooler into it and
will continue to operate properly now
sadly it does take a few minutes to get
through this pesky plastic packaging say
that three times fast
but this packaging does seem to mess up
every USB hub unboxing but I did cut
those few minutes out for your enjoyment
so right now you're looking at an
overview of what you get in the Box it's
very simple of course you get the power
cable that plugs into the back of the
hub and that'll plug into an outlet in
the wall you'll also get the cable to
plug in the USB hub to the back of your
computer that'll connect it to the USB
hub and of course you'll get the seven
port hub itself the earth geek gives me
then you probably know what the sub can
do if you're using a ton of USB ports or
peripherals like a keyboard a mouse
external hard drive microphone and USB
monitor a printer a dock etc you
probably don't have enough ports on your
computer to handle it all so there's
seven port hubs you'd satisfy your needs
at 2.0 speeds that never really let you
down
you can see that there are two USB ports
on top of the hub and the rest are
around the sides the hub isn't gonna be
sitting on my desk so it's not really
important to me where the ports are but
if you do plan on setting something like
this on top of your desk in plain view
you're probably going to want to pick up
something we're all seven ports face the
same direction organization
overall I really like this up I'll go
from eight ports to 14 since that's to
plug in somewhere I'll save some desk
space by plugging things in underneath
my desk into this hub and it'll overall
contribute to a nicer cleaner setup so
this has been a high-definition unboxing
and first impressions from mkbhd and
thanks for watching these